an American couple who survived a deadly
volcanic eruption in New Zealand is
filing a lawsuit today against a tour
company and a cruise line the eruption
of Pocari white island volcano in
december killed 21 people mostly
tourists Matt and Lauren URI claim Royal
Caribbean and IV tours New Zealand
Limited did not warn them of heightened
volcanic activity on the island before
the excursion in their first US network
TV interview the newlyweds opened up to
us about the terrifying eruption and
difficult months of recovery some
viewers may find the images in this
report a little difficult to watch you
guys met on was it match calm ready to
give up at that point and he messaged me
and you know he seemed great two years
later
Lauren and Matt URI said I do and this
past December the newlyweds took a
honeymoon cruise to Australia and New
Zealand
we started off having the time of our
lives and then it just turned out to be
just him on December 9th they took an
excursion to the white island volcano
snapping these pictures near the crater
soon after the volcano erupted and run
in less than a minute they were engulfed
in scalding ash and smoke Matt and
Lauren took cover behind a rock it was
just pitch black you couldn't see
anything in front of you and you could
just feel your skin burning and getting
pelted with rocks it was terrifying
could you even see each other oh no she
was holding my wrist but I had no idea
she would other than that that she was
there I genuinely thought that was the
end of my life and I thought that was in
Laurens life severely burned and barely
breathing Matt and Lauren found their
way to a tour boat which rushed them to
the mainland you ended up in hospitals
600 miles apart
yeah it's a hospital that we originally
were at couldn't handle all the burn
victims both were put in medically
induced comas and underwent skin grafts
and plastic surgeries it would be nearly
two months before they were reunited
back in the u.s. were you grateful to be
alive if you want me to be honest at
times I I kind of wished maybe it would
be easier if I wasn't I am now but at
the time when I was in New Zealand I
couldn't do anything I couldn't go to
the bathroom by myself I couldn't brush
my teeth and I I just was wondering if I
would ever be normal again
now home in Virginia the URIs are going
through painful laser procedures to
increase mobility and break down their
scars I imagine it's been easy to sleep
with this we have to sleep in separate
beds because we're just between the
tossing and turning and general
discomfort there's no way we can share a
bed right now it sucks
I can only imagine Lauren what's the
number part for you I don't like the
person I see when I look in the mirror I
don't like my obviously my burns the
scars I don't feel beautiful I'm afraid
he doesn't think I'm beautiful which he
tells me repeatedly he dies but I just
it's it's just really it's really hard
the URIs are suing both Royal Caribbean
and the New Zealand tour company
maritime attorney Michael Winkelman when
they're going to offer a short excursion
to their passengers they have a duty to
reasonably inspect the excursion to make
sure that it's safe in the weeks prior
to their trip the islands volcanic alert
level was raised to two level three
means an eruption had we known that
there is absolutely no way we would have
ever set foot on that yeah can you see
normalcy now nor
a little bit yeah I owe it all to him I
really do he's been my rock he's been
everything to me
in a statement to CBS News Royal
Caribbean said quote we respectfully
declined further comment while the
investigation is still proceeding we
reached out to eye detours New Zealand
limited for comment but they have not
yet we have not yet heard back Gail the
URIs face surgeries monthly for at least
the next year possibly more they are
hoping however to get a redo on their
honeymoon that's what they're looking
for I hope they get that but what struck
me is how tender they looked at each
other yeah I always I love love I'm a
sucker for that but as a woman when she
said if no one else thinks you're
beautiful you want your husband to think
so yeah when he said I do I do I can't
imagine going through this without each
other no but their faces look good so
you think oh it's not so bad until you
see those pictures that's right what
stuff we want him to be okay